joining us on the line is Warren Nord
he's an intellectual property bankruptcy
and litigation lawyer at Noren law in
the dallas-fort Worth area
he just represented at Shelly Luthor who
of course was the owner of salon ala
mode and she was arrested for opening
her salon against stay at home orders
and released yesterday Warren thanks so
much for joining show really appreciate
it thank you
so why don't you start by giving us sort
of the facts of the case
what exactly did Shelley Luthor do in
what fashion was she looking to open her
salon again okay so she closed when
everybody told everybody said we've got
to close and then one week but by two
weeks by a month goes by Shelley is told
of a lawsuit that we were putting
together that was challenging a lot of
these a lot of these executive orders as
you know there's a governor's executive
order that there's a county judge
executive order and then there's a city
executive order and then you have some
code enforcement guy that's enforcing
his version of whatever those are and so
it's very strange across the state you
have a lot of different executive orders
being affected the impact impacting a
lot of people a lot of different ways so
Shelly joined with that effort which was
filed and four of the nine members of
the Texas Supreme Court filed
concurrence and said hey we'll come talk
to you later on this but you got to talk
to her to talk to the district courts
first so while that was going on she
said I can't wait I've got I've got
stylists that are starving I'm gonna
open and so we had a long talk and I
promise you bad I told her this could
happen you can go to jail and she
understood that so she opened on the
24th I think it was and then she's that
same day clay Jenkins the county judge
of Dallas County brought her a had a
minion bring her a cease and desist
letter which he has no power and right
but he did and then she got a citation
and then the city of Dallas filed suit
saw an injunction and then we had an
injunction hearing I came back local
rules in Dallas says if I get two hours
of notice before a TR Oh Harry but I
didn't get that and so we had a I walked
in from lunch and they said the court
wants to talk to you okay here we are
and so we had a TR o hearing temporary
restraining order and said you got
you gotta not operate anymore she
continued to operate and so a few days
later the city of Dallas filed a request
for show till cause for filing for
finding it to contempt and then we had
that contempt area and of course that's
been all over the news you've seen that
before so we had the contempt area the
court actually I'll just give a moment
the court did not come down as hard as
it could have and said it could continue
to operate the salon has continued to
operate since at first reopen that is
paying a fine of $500 a day then we
filed so she was remanded to the custody
that day on the 5th all day the 6th we
wrote a writ of habeas corpus petition
and the morning of the 7th yesterday at
the Supreme Court reacted and here we
are so when she was looking to reopen it
sounds like miss Luther was doing so in
responsible fashion she wasn't just
saying come in here willy-nilly you know
fill up the fill up all of the seats sit
on each other that she was attempting to
be responsible and how she reopened her
business correct that's correct
everybody wants to say okay it's you
you're open or not open in fact the new
executive order says you're just open
but you've got now you get to do some
things right we were doing those things
before we were required to just like a
lot of the grocery stores we're putting
out markers before they're required to
so the assumption has always been that
if we don't have a law or rule then
everybody's going to be as irresponsible
as possible certainly that you can find
examples of that Michelle and Luther is
not one of those she took off all the
magazines people would normally go
through there's no drinks hanging around
the chairs are parked you know six feet
apart from each other
nobody was allowed in interestingly
enough the cops came in the first time
and she said no you got to go back and
get your mask so that was kind of an
interesting point so when what are the
current restrictions in the city of
Dallas and there have been rumors that
this business is gonna be able to open
up anyway within within a week or within
a week and a half so what are the
current restrictions there as of today
salons can open and so that the funny
part is that so miss Luther is in jail
or was in jail for seven days or her
past crime of
we can summarize that as heresy against
the state now I'm not saying that you
should go around disobeying court orders
all the time or that the court wasn't
within this within as his right mind or
doing something crazy to not punt it to
not punish or at all we just felt like
it went over the top
the the current restrictions allow
restaurants 25% they allow a lot of
things at 25% they don't allow the bars
or gymnasiums and so that those are
still I think it's actually they're at
25 percent - the bars are still closed
okay so they're here's the problem with
executive orders when you when you
legislate by an executive order you
don't have the normal process and so you
have to make these consistent changes if
you're a restaurant that serves in the
bar often so you have the 51% over
alcohol you can't operate even if you've
got a full restaurant so all of these
bars are lookin run as a restaurant but
the executive order doesn't want them to
do that so over a period of time we
expect more reasonableness in our rules
nobody would have filed this lawsuit
were open two days after when you
thought the virus is gonna be zombie
walking dead we're all young plague but
weeks and weeks later we expect these
rules to tighten not be more rational so
people are obviously very upset about
all this jelly Luther became a cause
celeb as well she should because she is
speaking for literally hundreds of
thousands of people across the country
who work at small businesses millions of
people who work at small businesses who
are saying that these lockdowns are just
not they're just it is not possible to
go on this way so if people are angry at
the authorities which level of authority
should people be angry at I've seen some
people angry at the local authorities in
the Dallas area some angry at the judge
I've seen some people who are angry at
the governor saying that the governor
has not been clear about exactly what
the what the orders should be and what
exactly the the standard should be
across the state well it's a typical
problem you have you know you're
governing by executive order Fiat you
need to have feedback and so the people
that are enforcing this are the ones
that actually the most direct feedback
in the hinterlands and backwoods of
Texas it's the sheriff who walks around
I am the law and does whatever he wants
and he says I'm enforcing the governor's
edicts and he just he does literally
what he wants
locally it's often a code enforcement
guides that's working on to the Dallas
Dallas has the fourth amended emergency
regulations not a law treated like a law
but it's not a lot and so those people
and these the problem is these people
kind of fly under the radar
who knows who their County Commission
that is or were through their City
Council's people or what I what I want
people to do is to remember the anger
that they feel right now in May when we
elect the City Council people and these
mayors so that they understand no you do
have an impact on our life and sometimes
that impact is a little over the top so
how is your client doing today I mean
obviously it's been a very tumultuous
week how's she doing today well it's a
she's doing very well I think she's out
visiting some people right now you know
she was in there for two nights it's a
long enough to find out that you don't
want to be there very long so she's
going to take a few days and she's got a
lot of death threats and of course
people who don't want to work don't want
her to succeed so she's taking a few
days she's not doing any mass
appearances although she's doing some
some some local media and some national
media Ben if I could if I could just say
that that what we need to do is we need
to to get feedback to the people that
are issuing executive orders which you
just asked me about a minute ago but I
would ask since you're an attorney there
are a hundred thousand attorneys I
should not be getting all these phone
calls right and I didn't start off as a
constitutional you know theorists I'm
just a business guy but but there are a
hundred thousand a lot of people are
very competent and I shouldn't be
getting calls from North Carolina
because nobody in North Carolina keep
doing this but what I do like and what
Shelly's done and this is where she's
really done is is provide an example to
a lot of people that my understanding is
the governor of Massachusetts said I
don't want to be another Texas as he
opened up two golf courses so people
need to understand that there this is
not an economics versus people issue
this is a people versus people issue we
can't say you guys have to take all the
sacrifice I'm only going to hear that
from people who have given all of their
money and emptied themselves up well if
you want to do that to show that you're
willing to sacrifice that
you couldn't ask other people to do the
same well-worn orhid thank you so much
for joining the program the lawyer for
Shelley Luther among other things his
firm is Noren law in the dallas-fort
Worth area really appreciate the time
sir thank you
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content